but we love people here coming to the
show with a passion for riding I love
riding as well and you started really
young right I started I'm probably like
you're young now but I mean younger I
started writing when I was 12. so I
started writing books I always loved to
read like many kids and 12 was the age
where I was like I think I can do this
and the Magical part about being 12 is I
truly believed I was going to write a
book and get published like the next day
and like be on a show like this like the
next but that's a great thing actually
about being young yeah it's the best
thing because you only do things because
you love it when you're that age and so
I loved to write so it's like I'm gonna
write a book and get published and so I
wrote the book I Googled how to get
published I knew you had to get a
literary agent and I started reaching
out to agents when I was 12 like from my
bedroom and and yeah
that's so cool not not successfully I
got hundreds of rejections like and it
was just the start of like the hundreds
and hundreds of rejections and my
parents had no idea I was like emailing
agents in my bedroom like they had they
were like why are you crying I was like
no no reason
um
I knew it was possible like there was a
so bold yeah so I knew that there was a
path so I just kept doing it and writing
another book and then all the rejections
and then another one and another one and
by the time I reached College I'd
written like five books all of them
rejected but I I felt like I was getting
closer and there was so much hope yeah I
love that you that says a lot about you
yeah you hope out of that situation a
lot of people would be deterred though
yes like they would but I think some of
us like I did better as a child too when
everybody I did get a door slammed it
almost makes you instill more confidence
in yourself and your gifts your talents
and go no I know this is what I'm
supposed to do some people it drives and
I feel like that definitely not for me
yeah yeah I feel like all of us know
rejection well in this industry yep yep
and that sucks and it's not always easy
to get back up no it's taking me down
quite a few times yeah and like well
that's so it's over yeah on the towel
saw the numbers it's been fun all the
numbers I saw the numbers and it's not
great I could only hope that like my
daughters have the drive that like what
made you what where do you think that
comes from I mean my mom is an immigrant
from Colombia and like my dad like
didn't go to college like he I watched
my parents like have to work so hard and
they always told us like you can do
anything you just have to keep working
really hard and like and and they were
so supportive like they paid for our
college and everything so like there's
so much privilege in that like to be
able to go to college and like have a
support system and have them like really
believe from the beginning like they did
eventually find out I was emailing
agents after like after I went to school
for it and I went to college for right
yeah
what is my daughter doing in her bedroom
right now like I'm like well yeah always
on the computer and so they they really
did like support my dream and um and and
believe in me but yeah it was really
tough like I'm sure seeing your kid go
through so many rejections obviously I'm
so glad I didn't stop
um but it is tough to see that and to
experience it but I always just believed
it would happen just not the way it
happened I guess yeah I love the way it
happened so before you tell us how you
were able to finally get published can
you share what the book's about sure I
love this yes so it's called light Lark
um it's a young adult fantasy it's about
an island that appears every hundred
years to host a game where six rulers
fight to break their deadly curses so
every ruler has a different person I
want to see the movie yeah I want the
whole series yeah I love stuff like that
all of the curses are uniquely Wicked
and to break all of them one of the six
rulers has to die and one will win his
powers okay betrayals there's plot
twists you don't know who's lying who's
telling the truth until the very last
page yes I know
yes
absolutely yes oh my God that's really
cool thank you I can't believe you got
turned down it's like such a great idea
and a lot of people love that field we
love that fiction and it's nice escapism
from reality some of the parallels can
be similar sometimes when Publishers
rejected light Lark Alex put put she put
together this Tick Tock video and I
gotta show you
thank you
[Music]
like I feel like what that is is like a
vision board for like what do we want
the film to look like like it was like
aesthetically so rad all the images my
favorite being that like bridge too yes
I don't know I don't know what that said
yeah let's talk about therapy later but
why did you want to post that so at that
point almost every publisher had
rejected it they loved the book but they
said this is such a tough market and
like it's so hard to break through so
they said no and I truly felt like if I
could just get this out to readers and
ask them like would you read a book
about this I felt like I couldn't be the
only one who would read this book and I
put everything I left into it so I
posted it just kind of like a silent
plea to avoid like please please like
someone like see this and and want it
and within like five hours it had no
views and so I was like oh my gosh I'm
proving Publishers right like no one
wants this book and so I almost deleted
it because I was like this is bad but I
left it up I had nothing to lose at that
point and the next morning I was in a
parking lot and I randomly checked the
app and it went viral I had like over a
million views yeah yeah and then a week
later it went to auction yeah oh yeah
this is me finding out that it debuted
number one on the New York Times the
seller list which is like a dream
um and it's been on there for 10 weeks
ever since it came out yeah oh my God
like what a way to take your power back
in this situation because I was telling
her in the commercial like it it's a
really cool thing and I can relate in
this sense of like having people help
your career happen like me like
auditioning like literally I got door
slammed on my face before I had to go on
a competition yeah to have people like
vote for me and be like see somebody
likes it like you know it's like and
that's the kind of similar and I love if
there's a power to that and a leverage
to that like in this industry and I'm so
happy thank you so much yeah yeah it's
so cool and now you you do have a movie
deal as well right you know it's
lightlock is being made into a movie by
Universal and the producers of Twilight
which is just a guide It's a dream
[Applause]
it's a dream and just like you said like
I would not be here if it wasn't for
every single person who supported me
when no one else did like they saw the
potential all the readers who who saw
that video now bought it and are
hopefully going to see the movie and
just to have their support like I'm so I
owe it all to them yeah I love it it
literally is this whole episode is about
passion like believing in yourself
that's so cool I'm this is such honestly
this would make a great movement like
the whole like how it started and how it
ended and like to keep believing in
yourself when you get knocked down
because we all get doors everybody
always thinks like oh so easy they did
this and it happened I'm like you didn't
see all the previous pre-game yeah it
happened like so that's so cool I'm so
happy for you thank you so much I can't
wait to hold the series I want to read a
whole series of it I can't wait to see
the movie I'm very excited for you thank
you so much and I know some actors
and I'm not one of them but I'll write
you a pretty song
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]